Policy set,
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, Dave Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode.
For today's Rawkode Live, we are taking a
look at not one, not even two, but
three different projects from the cloud native ecosystem
to help you improve your security posture and
container image pipeline.
Those projects are Notary, OraS, and Ratify.
And joining us today,
I'm pleased to welcome Yi from Microsoft,
a maintainer,
or two of these projects,
Notary
and Radify and a contributor to OraS. Welcome
Yi. How are you?
Hi, David. I'm good. Hello, everyone.
For anyone who has not met you before,
could you please give us a little bit
of history, flavor, context, and tell us all
about yourself, please? Sure.
My name is Yi. So
I'm currently senior product manager at Microsoft.
My main focus is on the container's secure
supply chain.
I'm also the
project maintainer for the CNCF project, notary project,
and the RADify project.
And also, I'm spending
time working on the
ORIS project.
Yeah.
So
my
main
goal is to build in the solutions
and the tools to help users,
customers to secure their supply chain by using
authentic content, their images and other
effects.
All right. Yep. Now, maybe a little bit
of a broad question here, but let's open
it up to some conversation.
Aren't if we're shipping containers to to a
Kubernetes project,
aren't we secure? Like, what is the state
of security today if you are just deploying
your first
pod and container image to a Kubernetes cluster?
Yeah,
I think it
yeah. So so today, in cloud native world,
the Container Warehouse application is where
we built it popular, especially
the Kubernetes and the different distributions
that
your vendor provided.
So security remains
the very hot topic,
as you know.
Recent years, there are many
cyber
attack on the software supply chain, especially with
the
with the growing
of the open source
projects. Right? So malicious code vulnerabilities could be
injected into those
open source projects, and those could be the
dependencies
for your container images that you are going
to deploy or use in your pipeline, in
your
Kubernetes environment.
Yeah, I think that's the main topic we'll
be able to talk about today about the
security.
Okay.
And the three projects that you're going to
show us today, they're all CNCF projects.
But what are they? Can you give us
the kind of TLDR on what is ORS,
what is notary, and what is ratify? And
if you're gonna cover this in your your
demo and stuff, please feel free just to,
like, say, let's move straight to the demo.
But if you wanna give us just the,
you know, the thirty second pitch for each.
Yeah.
Sure. Before I start to intro those
open source projects, I want to talk about
the more about the
backgrounds
and also
a systematic way for securing the software supply
chain for your containerized workloads.
Actually,
in the,
to superior,
container supply chain, there are different
aspects you needed to consider. For example,
once
how do you scan your container images and
you will receive some vulnerability reports, right? How
do you want to patch your container images?
How do you want to fix your application,
one of our codes.
Those are related to the one of the
management.
So today, we will talk about more about
the authenticity
and the integrity of
the contented images
That means that
so
as a developer when you want to use
some, for example, base images
or utility images,
you may want to ask the questions How
do I trust
those images? Right? Well,
that's where do those images come from? How
do I trust those images that come from
really the
the company or the organization I trust? This
is one question, and this is about the
authenticity.
Another question
often asked by developer
is that how do I ensure those images
are not tampered with during the distribution because
images move around the registries,
right, from your SAS ID system
to
registry
and to public registry or from public registry
to your private registry,
right, from public cloud to your on premise
cloud or even other cloud environment.
So how can you ensure
during this distribution?
How can you ensure the images are not
tampered with by the
bad actors?
So those authenticity and the integrity are
the topic today.
And in
the container supply chain area, so
I think the last
KubeCon
twenty twenty four
in North America
and one of the notary project maintainer, also
my colleague gave a very good keynote
talking about the
whole end to end solution
and the tools that can be used for
securing the
service supply chain. So I want to talk
that process a bit because
later on, when I show you hands on,
you will know
parts
that will be covered by those tools and
what's the purpose to use that tool to
achieve what go? Yeah.
So in order Yeah. Yeah, please.
Well, I just want to, you know, make
sure I fully understand the problem statement here.
Right? So when we're talking about patient images
around, like you said, you go from public
registries to private registries to inside of your
cluster.
Those are just
bytes and bets being thrown around the wild
internet. We need some sort of,
we can't trust them right away. We need
to be able to prove that we trust
them.
ORS,
I'm not super familiar with any of these
tools. So anything I say wrong, just jump
in there and say, no, no, that's not
right. ORS
is a tool that we can use to
push and pull from different registries to the
best of my knowledge.
Now, when I say let's run and I'll
just pick a random project here, let's say
Valky another CNCF project. I wanna run this
in my cluster. I say, I wanna run
version one in my manifest,
the kubelet and container D are responsible for
pulling that and putting that in the cluster.
If I pin that to a SHA, like
say instead of saying V1, I just use
a SHA.
How secure am I at that point? And
do I still need to bring in other
tools such as Notary and Rettify? I want
to understand where
that gap in my knowledge is to a
certain degree.
Yeah.
So I do that AORUS is the tool
to manage the OSA artifacts
in the OCI compliant registry,
but here to the OCI standards.
So for folks who
who doesn't know the OCI, OCI means Open
Content Initiative
is
also
Linux
Foundation projects that to
provide a standardized way to managers' images,
artifacts,
content the runtime,
and how to distribution
for
in a container world. That that is their
goal.
So ORS is the tool that managers
OSA identified
in the container OSAI
compliance
registry
according to the OCI standards.
So that is the purpose for AURAs. And
you mentioned that the share,
the digest of images, right? That is a
very good point because the digest is the
unified way to identify an image.
But
you can use the digest to identify an
image, but how do you know that the
images is coming from a trusted source?
Right?
It could be yeah. The digest, no
one changes, but the image is actually coming
from malicious hacker. How do how do you
know that? Right? So that is the purpose
for the yeah, we are introducing the product
now, our project now. That is the purpose
for the Notre project.
The Notre project,
the mission is Notre project is actually
a set of specifications and the tools. And
the mission of Notre Project is
to use a standard way across
multi clouds to provide the tools, solutions
for users to ensure integrity
and the authenticity
of their images and also other artifacts used
in the contender world. Yeah,
so I'm
by mentioning the other artifacts, so contender images
are the main one, but it could be
some other artifacts, for example, ham charts, right?
Ham charts are very popular for the Kubernetes.
Yeah.
So using another project,
you can using the
by using the digital signature,
you can ensure the authenticity and the integrity
from a producer point of view, you can
cite
from a consumer point of view, you can
verify it to ensure it's really from
from the trusted source and then not modified
during the distribution.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, the digest approach is
obviously
what we've been told over the years is
the best practice, but
the developer experience of that is not great.
I can honestly say, I don't think I've
been to a company or worked with a
company where they've just penned to digest and
they're manifest. It just never happened. And I
feel like,
well, it's best practice. We need to find
a way to make that easier to consume.
Notary is one of those projects that I
say really does fill in some gaps there
because
it allows you to break in what as
we're going to see, allows you to bring
it into the loop and still get the
convenience of tags, but still have some sort
of trust and integrity pipeline that says, okay,
this is the thing I want to run.
Now what about ratify? We haven't mentioned that
yet. Where does that fit into the puzzle?
Yeah. Ratify is
a
very flexible
verification
engine.
It's built
on top of extensible
framework that you can plug the different,
wildfires
to verify,
reference artifacts
to ensure,
the artifacts,
is secure from various aspects.
For example,
second issue we just talk about is to
ensure the integrity and the authenticity,
right? Ratify can
validate the signature for example produced by the
notary projects,
but there are some other artifacts
for example,
we, I think at the beginning, I talk
about the vulnerability management.
Right? So,
for container images, you can ensure they are
trusted, but how do you know whether they
contain
vulnerabilities?
So Ravodify can what verify the vulnerability
reports
or fundings associated
with that content images. For example,
if your company
you you have the policy that no critical
or high vulnerabilities are allowed, Ratify can
do that,
with policies.
And there
are some other,
artifacts like, SPAM, software B of materials,
So RADIFY can also
validate,
the artifact to ensure,
the software are compliant because software have a,
for example, have a different license, right? So
RADIFY is actually the verification engine
to validate
reference artifacts
associated with your contender images. But the goal
is the same, to safeguard your contender
security.
And the Ratify currently
working
with
OPAC Gatekeeper,
open policy agent gatekeeper.
Gatekeeper is the policy engine
in the Kubernetes. So Radify worked with Gatekeeper
to help secure
your
containerized workload deployed on the Kubernetes.
Very, very cool. I'm looking forward to this
then. Alright. I think we've covered enough of
the bases to set the stage,
if you will. If you could now share
your screen, I'm happy to hand over and
get hands on and see the demo that
you've prepared for us.
Sure.
Let me adjust my window. Yeah. Of course.
Take your time.
Alright. Your screen is shared. The font looks
great. Take it away.
Thank you.
Yeah. So today, I will
show you how to secure
your containers'
workloads,
containerized workloads
from end to end point of view.
When I say end to end, it means
starting from
your build, your container images
and you assign your container images
to
generate the digital signature and those signature can
be associated
with your container images.
And then later on, you'll want to distribute
your container images
to from your build system or CSID pipelines
to another
environment
for the production usage.
And
on your production environment,
I will demonstrate how to use
Ratify and the Gatekeeper
to prevent,
deploy, untrusted
images.
Okay? So that's basically the process.
So
what I will do today,
you can do that on your, actually,
Windows
laptop
because I use
Docker desktop to set up the Docker environments.
I use the WSL2
for
the Linux environment
and I download the tools from Notre Projects,
Rottify,
and Auras,
and also,
the Gatekeeper.
So I will show show them.
So basically, everything you,
I
will do today,
you can do it on your laptop. Of
course, if you have a Mac
or Linux
workstation, you you can also do that as
well.
Okay.
So on the window you you see is
the
WSDL two.
So I already
downloaded
Noteproject tool Notation,
which is the CLI tool for sign and
verify content images and other artifacts.
So let me show you.
Yeah. This is the tool I downloaded from
Docker project GitHub.
By the way, I also prepared
a README file, so after
this podcast,
can share it out so you can
try them. And that README file is located
on my GitHub repo if you
you go to my
GitHub
using my name, y I v h a
one, you can immediately find that.
Yeah. I'll make sure that link is in
the description afterwards as well for anyone watching
Yeah. For the fact. Thank you.
So this is the
notation CLI.
I also
download the ORAS
tool. These two are ready
to use.
And for Radify and Gatekeeper,
they will be
deployed on the Kubernetes. I will show them
later.
Okay?
So
yeah, in this directory,
I also have
several files. I will explain them later on.
The first is the Dockerfile. So normally, you
will have this
in your CICD build system. You will have
a Dockerfile to build your content images. Right?
This is just an example of Dockerfile.
And then today, I will also,
demo something different but more secure, and we
will would like to promote,
the usage in the near
future for the
for us, intend the images.
So,
today, so for most,
in most,
solutions,
the contender images
needed to be pushed to
a registry
that signs the contender images in the registry,
right? So that means the contender images after
you build,
you will
push them from your file system
to the registry.
For example, you use Docker build and
it will create images on your file system,
and you use the Docker push to push
those images to the registry,
then you sign it. This is
the way
notation already supported, but today I will demo
more advanced the usage.
That's
you build your container images, and then the
images are on your file system,
right,
before
your you copy or push your images from
your trusted domain, your file system
to other,
for example, registry or other
file system. For example, we we have a
some customer they are using Lgap environment right
so you cannot easily just copy
the images
between the registries normally
you will
copy them as
using some file transfer mechanism.
So I will show you how to do
that in a more secure way to distribute
your content images.
And at the same time, you can still
have your signatures associated
with your content images.
The digest will not change.
Everything keeps the same as you just built.
Okay?
Now I will I have this Dockerfile.
You can take this environment as your, for
example, SICD system. I just use the command
line to simulate the process.
Okay? Then
so
let's first export
some environment.
Yeah. I will use my
I will use the
DocHarp
to simulate the registry.
It could be any registry, for example, public
any other public registry you want to use
or any private registry.
I will give the name.
Okay,
and I will then start to build.
Okay, I start a new Buildx environment,
then I will use the Docker
Buildx
build.
I will just plan this later on.
Yeah, the tag will be the
image
that the
environment variable
that we just set.
So with this command,
you will build
the image in
OCI image layout format.
And
for Docker Builder
command, either we will generate a tarp or
for the OCI image layout.
For folks who is not familiar with OCI
image layout, OCI image layout is also from
the
OCI image standard
from the OCI
community.
It is the standard way for you to
manage OCI
images
or artifacts
on your file system.
So simply,
you can think this
is just a table,
and it contains
directory and the files. Will show you later.
Just out of curiosity,
if you mind, are you happy to take
questions throughout? Is that okay?
Yeah,
I think so.
So I don't use build X very much,
but does Docker not build OCI images by
default
as the layout?
If not, does it use something else? Or
does this output just specify to do it
as a tar file? Is that the main
thing that's different here?
Yeah. If you want to produce the OSA
image layout,
you will use this command. This is the
only command to support produce
OSA image layout
using Docker. Okay. Yeah. So normally, you just
use Docker builds
or some other commands that is build to
the container images not in the OCA image
layout format.
Okay.
Thanks.
Okay. I think it is successful, although there
is a warning. So this is the TARC
work.
So
so let's
use tar to
extract it into
a directory.
Okay, choose the directory we just created
Okay. Then we go to this directory.
You see it is
yeah.
Actually, OSA image layout is just the files
and directory
according to the OCI media layout specification.
And let's
check this index.
Yeah. You will see the media type. You
if you are familiar with the manifest of
the images,
the
media type,
and also you see the annotation, it is
actually the image that we want to tap,
right, into the
the registry.
And this is the tag,
and this is the architectures.
So basically, in the registry, they are similar
structure.
So that is the
how do you say? That is the benefits
of the OCA image layout because you can
easily
move from file system to any disk
any registry or even any other file system.
Okay.
So why
there could be a question that why I
needed to, because it is already a tab
or a file. Why I
needed to
inspect it into a directory? Because another project,
when signed the contented images, it will produce
detached signature.
Means detached signature means the signature is actually
a different artifact.
So if you store this signature
in the registry, it will have a different
manifest, but that manifest will have an association
with the contained images so that you will
know
the signature is for
which
container images.
So I
extract the the container images into
this directory.
Now I'm going to sign the container images,
and the signature will be produced inside this
directory as well.
Okay. So before
we using the notation tool to assign
images,
there's another important thing I want to talk
about.
Because when you assign content images,
Notre projects
utilize the PKI infrastructure,
public key infrastructure.
Actually,
you need to have
a private key key files and the certificates.
You're using the private key for signed and
then the images.
And from
the file
point of view, they will using the certificates.
And that the certificates
inside it it contains a public key and
you use the public key to verify
the signature and the certificate
include any
signer information.
Those are the folks that you also need
to verify you you should trust.
So
so this is the the basic knowledge here
for for the DG signature.
And
actually,
the keys and certificate are quite critical,
right? If any malicious users get the private
key,
they can sign it, right?
So
to securely store your keys and certificate, you
can use any
popular
key management system, for example,
from
error,
error providing the error keywords,
If you are using the
AWS cloud,
you can choose the AWS Assigner.
And
recently,
another project
was adopted by Alibaba Cloud,
so if you are in the Alibaba Cloud
environment, you can choose Alibaba
Cloud Secrets Manager.
We also support
HashKob Vault, but, it is in
the R5 version, it's still an early version,
so if,
folks are interested into,
this, pain management system, feel free to join
the community,
we can talk about how to enhance
that.
So today,
for the hands on purpose
for for you to easily
try the sign and verification
experience,
I use self signed certificates
And actually, Notary Project two, Notation provide a
very convenient way for you to generate a
self a self signed certificate
for
trying the signed and the verification experience.
So notation has the cert command,
certificate command,
in short cert,
and you can use it to generate
test
certificates.
For example, I
generate
for my company.
You you can use any name here.
This is what I choose, and you make
it a default
certificates
and the keys so that you can use
it easily
later on.
Okay, you see I
generated
the
test key
and the test certificate.
Those are stored in the notation
config directory.
Okay.
And then you can use SERP lists.
You can see this is the one I
just created.
The second one is what I test for
the hands on today.
Okay? And you can also check
key
using notation key command.
You will see I also have a key
for my test
before this broadcast.
This my company, this is the key I
just created, and you see this
star, it means it is the default key.
So with that, we have the key and
certificate
created.
As I just mentioned,
in production, normally, you will store those keys
in
a key management system. So today, those are
the self signed key. They stored on my
file system.
Okay. To sign OCI image layout, actually, notation,
currently, the feature in notation is experimental.
So I needed to
enable the experimental
flag
notation
x.
Experimental.
Okay. That's correct.
Then
I can sign.
But before I sign, I want to check,
for example,
just to show
you that there's no signature
for the OCI image layout.
I can use notation list,
in short, ls command
to
OSI
layout.
The layout I just created.
Okay.
So on the screen,
can see that
this warning for experimental feature.
And because I use TAC,
there's warning as well. It is suggested to
use
the SHA, which is more secure because SHA
is the unified
way to identify images.
But for the demo purpose, I just need
to use
the tag V1 and which will be
shown on the doc
later on. Will show you.
You'll see
these images
identified
by the SHA
has no associated signature.
Okay? This is before we sign.
Okay. Now we have everything. We have a
key,
and we have a certificate which will be
used later on for verification.
We checked the OCI layout.
There's no certificate
no
signature generated.
Now I'm going to sign it.
It is very easy because I made the
key default.
Right? I I have set a default key.
So I will going to set sign the
OSAT layout,
Net Monitor.
Okay.
Okay. It's very quick because it's all on
my local machine. So successfully
assigned
these images.
You remember this
digest
three forty seven. So if I can scroll
up this image layout index file, see 3472,
right?
So it is the image we want to
send,
then we check whether they have signatures. I
use the same command I've got
before
notation list.
Okay.
You will see a very nice graph
output.
This is the container images, right, identified by
this digest and
that is the
notary project signature,
associated
with this container images
and it is, as explained
before, it is the detached signature, Right?
So it has its own manifest, and this
is the digest for that signature.
Okay?
So
we complete the sign.
Till now, we have the signature.
We we have the contained images on my
file system.
It is still under my trusted domain. Right?
It is on my system. So imagine it
is your CICD system or build the system
in a private environment or any
public cloud
host environment.
It is on your environment.
It is not
in any other registry yet. It is on
your file system. It is secure.
Then we go to the
OCA media layout, the directory. Let's check the
index file again.
You see they are something more. Right?
So
previously, you only see this
metadata
for the
images in OCI image layout format.
Now you'll see there's addition
metadata
for
signature If you remember this is the digest
for signature I scroll up a bit
You can see
the same
digest.
So you you will see there are two
manifests,
and one is for the images,
another is for the
for the signature.
And there are some other annotation.
This is sample print is actually the
sample print for the certificate.
Because we use self signed certificate,
there's only one.
In production,
normally, user will have a root certificate,
intermediate
certificate,
and the signed certificate.
So in production, you will see three.
Okay?
Okay. Then we completed the design process. We
we have everything
on my file Yeah.
Yeah, please.
So
when you've signed that with the notations CLI,
you've modified
the
OCI layout
image JSON artifact. Does that not change?
No. Didn't.
No. I didn't modify the image itself.
I just add a detached
signature,
another manifest into the OCI image layout directory.
So the image is still there under that
directory,
but I attached
another signature,
another separate artifact into that OCA image layout
directory.
It is similar like
in the registry, right? You have your container
image
stored in the registry.
It has its own
manifest
and the layers.
Then I add another
artifact,
in our case signature,
into the registry.
It has its own manifest and also layouts.
So in the registry, you have image signature
on your file system similarly
under that directory, although the directory name
could be
a bit confusing because it used the image
name, right, the the the repository name. So
it looks like I modified the
image, but actually not.
Actually,
that is just the directory for OCI image
layouts.
And under it, by checking the index, you
see there are two different manifests.
Right. Okay. Gotcha. Yep.
Okay. That makes The digest is yeah. Digest
is totally the same.
Okay.
Now I will
copy
the images using Auras. This is now the
Auras tool. Jump into the picture.
Okay. Auras manager artifacts
in OCI compliant registry.
So Auras,
in in this context, RRAS will copy the
OCI image layout
to a registry.
For example,
in the
in in our hands on, I use DocHub
for store the images.
But in your case, it could be
some private registry or any other
private other
public registry
based on your cloud environment.
And
the good part or the beautiful part is
that you see everything is actually
directory and files. Right?
You actually can make another
table
or
other
file transfer mechanism.
You can
transfer it from your
local file system
to any other,
for example, file system or storage
using your own file transfer mechanism,
your own secure way for transfer files.
For example, if you have air gapped environment,
you can actually copy the images and the
signature from your file system, your build system,
for example, to to a USB drive. Right?
Then you use that drive to your air
gapped environment you plug in.
Right?
And the the images and signature
are
the same, totally the same.
So it can leverage your current
file transfer mechanism,
the secure way to distribute
your
files or binaries as you did previously.
And from that environment,
you can,
for example, use Aura's to copy
the OCA image layout to the registry
for production usage.
So now what I will do today, I
will skip the process on how you transfer
these files.
Assume that you
copy these files using some file transfer mechanism
and copy it to your production environment.
So
now I'm on the production environment.
Okay?
Then you can use ORA's tool.
Actually, before that, let's use Auras tool to
check whether there is
the same image in
my
registry. I use DocHub to simulate.
So if you remember,
let me check.
Okay.
This image is not fun, right?
Okay. Now I'm on the
production environment
or the environment
that I will propagate the images to my
registry,
I use OrasCopy.
This means recursively.
It means that not only the image,
but also the signature associated
with the image
from OCI
layout
to
Okay.
It seems there's the
arrow.
Let me try again. I think Docker Hub
may just have been having a wee moment.
Yep.
Let me check.
Just a second.
Because all of the layers are one rule.
Yep. Let's
try it again.
There you go.
Yeah.
Okay.
If you remember, previously, I used this command
to discover whether this image exists or not.
Right?
So
let's check again.
Okay.
Now this image is is stored in the
DocHarp,
the same digest, you remember.
And it also has a signature associated
with the image.
Okay.
So now we
yeah.
We we have
first of previously, we have everything securely stored
on my file system. Right?
Then I use the secure way to transfer
images
and the signatures
to another secure environment,
which will
promote the image to production registry.
Then I use Aura's command to copy from
the OSAI image layout to the
production registry, I use DocHub for simulation. So
you see everything is now in my production
registry.
Okay.
Then we will go to the
verification part.
Okay. To verify
images, actually, it depends.
For example,
it could be, for example, I produce
base images,
and this base image is stored somewhere, and
then you will use in your environment to
use that base
images for building your own application image. Right?
So in that case,
the base image is actually consumed in a
CICD pipeline
system,
so that you can use notation tool
to validate
the signature of the base
images
to ensure they are trusted
before you use them. Right? So this is
one scenarios that you can validate the images
in your
build system, CICD pipeline.
Another
scenario is
about
the workloads on the Kubernetes. Right? So
you build your connected images. In the end,
you want to
run them in the Kubernetes to provide the
service to your customers.
So that is the scenario that you will
pull images from registry
and then deploy to the Kubernetes.
And in that case, we also needed to
do some validation,
verification to make sure those images that are
going to be pulled and the wrong
are trusted. Right?
So I will demo these two scenarios.
To demo the replication inside CD pipeline, I
will using Notation tool
to simulate it. So normally, we have a
currently, Notation
tool has been integrated with GitHub Actions,
Azure DevOps,
and the FluxCD.
And there will be more
SAS AD pipeline that we plan to integrate.
So if you are on the GitHub or
Azure DevOps or FluxCD,
you you will have a manager, the task
manager, the access actions
to use to
verify
the signatures.
So today, I will use the Notation CLI
to simulate the process. Actually, for those tasks,
they also integrate with the Notation CLI to
do that, but provide the management
experience.
I will use Notation tool
to demo it and show you the
how Notation
can trust
an image an instant nature.
Assume now we are on the CICD pipeline.
In order to verify
a container images,
for notation, we needed to set up
trust the store and trust the policy.
Trust the store means the
trust anchor,
means who you trust. It is based on
the PPA
system.
So normally,
there will be a CAE. Right? CAE issued
a signed certificate,
and those signed certificates
will be used for assigned content images. Just
now we demoed that using the self signed
certificate
to simulate this
hierarchy.
But in real world,
you trust the SCA,
your consumer,
your customer,
or
image verifier,
they trust the SCA.
Right? So trust store is where you store
the root SCA certificate
from the ZAID.
That is the trust anchor.
Then
you don't need to set up the trust
policy.
So in the trust policy, user needed to
specify some
properties. I will show you now.
So in order to,
set up a trust store,
to simulate,
you copy the root state certificate to to
our file system and then use that have
the trust or coordinate.
So in my case, I will copy
the route to say certificate.
If you remember, I have this, my company.
Right?
Cert.
So this is just to simulate. The route
stays. Normally,
the route stays dedicated from, say, they will
distribute
to through some web
storage or some preconfig
system
so that you can easily get.
So now I simulate. I copy this root
assay certificate,
distributed
or published the BIOS CA to
my local file system.
Okay.
I click.
So I have the root
say certificate.
I set up the trust door first.
Notation cert.
Okay.
Yeah. I want to mention that
at the beginning, I used the notation
cert
generate test. Right? This command.
So it actually
helped me to set up the trust tool
already. So I will show you.
It is already
set up if you use the generate
test.
So if the type is the same,
that this is the trustor name,
and this is the root certificate.
So in real world,
you needed to use notation
cert add command
to I add the root certificate that you
received from your signer.
The signer should publish the guide on how
to verify the signature.
The signer will know that
where the,
route to say certificate is, if they will,
publish,
the information in in the guide. So you
will use this command
and a store name, your store,
for example,
and the
file
to the trust store. Because we already have
this, so I don't need to do that.
This is command. It's just to show in
real world that you needed to use this
notation cert command to to add.
And then you can after that, you use
the notation cert
list
to check
whether the store is,
set up.
Then you needed to configure the trust policy.
Trust policy is actually a JSON document, so
I have a template here.
So let's take a look.
Maybe just let's edit.
Okay, it's a JSON
format.
This is the policy name, my policy, you
can give it any name.
And this is the
registry scope,
which is a list of
repositories.
So in our case, is that we
have our image with the tag V1.
Right? It is under the repository network.
And this is my
registry address.
So signature verification,
by default, is strict. It means that the
signature
integrity,
authenticity,
and the
revocation
checking,
expiry checking will be enforced.
There are some other values,
so, I will not demo
those values today, but, you can check out,
those values in Notreeable Project specification.
Could that register scope
be just your username, or do you have
to explicitly state every single image?
So currently,
you have to specify a list of repository,
not not the images, because
for another NET monitor,
we have V1, right? It could be V2,
V3.
We don't need to specify the tag. We
just need to specify the repository.
So currently, it is the list of repository.
We have a plan in the
future to support on different level, for example,
on registry level
or on the
namespace level.
So
that is for the
future. Yeah. Okay. Cool.
This
is the trustor
with this format,
trustor type,
trustor name.
Our name, I think, is called the company.
Right? Yes.
And this is the trust identity. Trust identity
is actually a subject the
distribute distinguished
name of your science science certificate.
I will show you how you can get
it. And normally, it will be also provided
by your
signer.
And actually, this is the identity you want
to trust.
You do not want to trust anyone
one else, because for root CA certificates
in real world, it can sign it can
issue
many
signed certificates, right? All those signed certificates,
are using the same root CA certificate.
So this is the identity you want to
trust.
So how can I get this
identity?
Normally, it will from your
signer
who will publish the document to mention this
is the identity you should trust.
But for our case,
for the self signed certificate, there is another
convenient way.
For example, you can use notation
cert
show command.
This one.
You can type
say a
store
mycompany.io
and mycompany.io
cert.
It will obtained some
details for the certificate.
That is a lot easier than trying to
remember the OpenSSL
incantation.
You. So you see the issuer subject,
they are the same. Right? So because it
is a self signed certificate,
So you can just copy this
to your trust policy.
So let's get back to the trust policy.
Basically, you copy it here.
Okay? So with trust policy
so I want to
highlight that
for another project,
when we want to verify something,
we start from zero trust.
You see,
before I set up a trust store and
trust policy, not not notation to trust no
one.
And for a user, you needed to be
clear who you want to trust. You can
just you you cannot just readily trust anything.
Use a well cut. In that case, even
you have the tools ready for sign verification
to verify, but still you increase your security
risk because you blindly
trust everyone.
So
we set up a trust store for
the anchor,
for the CA that we want to trust.
And then we set up the trust policy
to specify that
which images
we want to verify,
which will be specified by the trust scopes,
and also,
what is the trust angle coming from and,
who
we are going to trust.
Okay? So with that,
let's
notation import
this policy.
Sorry. I missed the policy
import.
I already have my test policy, so now
I have my company policy.
Okay. So after that, you will use policy
show.
You will see this is exactly the policy,
right, we used in the JSON file. It
is now imported into the notation
configuration.
Okay. With that, we can start to
verify
the images.
Notation verify
and image
sign.
Okay.
It's
pretty fast because we're on the local,
and we can use
verbose
flag to check more logs.
Yeah. You can see it's checking the signature
using the trust policy configuration,
and, this is the signature
digest if you remember previously we showed.
Okay. I cleared the terminal, so we cannot
see that. So this is the signature.
So maybe I can use the ORAS command
to discover.
You see, this is the digest for the
signature manifest.
This is the signature that Notation
Verify Commands verified against.
Okay.
Okay. Just now I demoed how to
do the verify
in a CICD pipeline
or build a system
that
normally
in the real world, it it is normally
that before you
want to use some other images to build
your application images, it could be base images
or utility images.
Before they want to use them for building
your own application
container images,
you in your CICD pipeline, you verify it
using Notation or any other
manager experience that integrate with Notation.
Okay.
I think that the last demo
will be how
we can ensure our workloads running on Kubernetes
is trusted.
Okay?
That,
we need the gatekeeper
and the ratify.
Okay. In the real world,
if you use some vendor's cloud
environment,
for example, if you are using Azure,
you can use Azure policy plus ratify.
You don't need to install
Gatekeeper.
Or from error,
there is a preview
policy
called AKS image integrity.
You can also try it.
That is actually a managed experience integrates both
Gatekeeper and the Routing plan. So you do
not need to install manually.
Or in
some other scenarios,
for example, you you you say you you
don't want to have the you don't want
to use Gatekeeper.
You want to use Keyverter.
That is also Okay.
You can
install Key Verner or any environment already integrated
with Key Verner
in any cloud,
you can use Key Verner
plus Notary Project Signature.
You can still verify not reproject signature. So
that is also
something beautiful that I mentioned for another project,
because we are aiming to be able to
standardize the tools
and produce standard interface, for example, in this
case, signature. So that no matter
what the tools
produce the signature,
because we have an author project specification,
you can also
build your own signature
tools using based on lottery project signature specification.
So no matter what the tool produce the
signature,
no matter what tool you want to consume
the signature, the signature format is standardized.
So that is the
beautiful thing that
basically you can choose any tools
based on your needs in any environment.
Okay. So today, I will demo Gatekeeper
plus Radify to help you to understand
the logic for the
signature verification on Kubernetes.
So Gatekeeper is actually
a Kubernetes native
policy controller.
So how it works? It is actually
intercepting
the API requests
and evaluate
them against
some policies.
So after evaluation,
it will make a decision whether go or
not go so that it can decide whether
the resource will be created,
modified,
or deleted.
That is how Gatekeeper
works as a policy controller.
But how
or why does Gatekeeper need to ratify?
Gatekeeper
actually
has the external data
provider interface.
So in order for Gatekeeper to make a
decision, Gatekeeper
needed to have data, right, to have a
data to evaluate against the policy,
then make a decision. So RADIFY,
in this case, serves as an external data
provider
to
feed Gatekeeper
with
its
verification
results
based on
Radify's verifier. For example, in our case,
Radify has the notation
as the verifier to verify
another project's signature. And Radify
provides these results to Gatekeeper.
And the Gatekeeper, it has its policy to
evaluate
whether it is go or not based on
the
data
from Ratify.
Then the results can be decided whether to
create, modify, or delete. So that's the whole
logic behind that.
Okay?
Then we needed to install Gatekeeper.
I think I have my
yeah. I actually use Kubernetes
that
created by the Docker desktop.
So I have everything
containerized
the toolings
provided by the Docker desktop. So let me
check
my Kubit is
running.
Okay.
It is running,
and the
so
I will use HAM. HAM is the tool
to manage your packages on Kubernetes.
It's popular.
Okay.
I already added because
I did some tests.
Now I want to install
Gatekeeper.
It's
yeah. This command.
It will install
Gatekeeper
from the repository I add.
It will install it in the Gatekeeper system,
this namespace.
And you see here what I just explained.
I set the
external data.
Basically,
I enable it so that the RADify can
communicate with Gatekeeper.
Now I
have filled it.
I will copy this namespace because it's long.
I will use it later.
Okay,
let's check the pot.
I just copied the namespace.
Okay. You see DataKeeper.
It's running now. It's very quick. Right?
Now let's
install the
RADify.
Yeah.
So just now, I downloaded the root state
certificate
into my file system. Right?
Actually, RADIFY will also use this root state
certificate as a trust anchor because Radify actually
integrates with
Notre project. So it follows the Notre project
specification
to set up the trust door and the
trust policy.
So I will show you a command, and
you will find it is very similar
for what we did for trust store and
the trust policy.
Let's make sure this repo
okay. This repo already
there.
This is the command to
install RADify.
Okay. And the same name
namespace as gatekeeper.
This assert rotation is actually
means the cert
that's used for the
secure connection between Radify and the gatekeeper. It
is not the cert that's related to the
site.
Okay. You see the SAT file. This is
actually means the root certificate
that use the bind notation.
So we just copy it to our local.
So it could be also
the HAM installation,
it could be also in your DevOps assistant
that you will execute,
and then the RADify package will be installed
in Kubernetes.
So this file could be on your
DevOps file system
or some storage.
And you set you see the trust policies,
the spreadsheet scope,
the same as we did for
our sensitive pipeline verifications error. Right?
And also the trust policy, the trust store,
the SA store,
and use the
first SA store that we we just set.
And
it is the identity we trust. We trust
this identity.
Right?
You see, it is the same
trust policy structure as we just did for
the CICD scenario using notation.
Okay.
With this,
just with this one command,
we install RADIFY,
we also configure RADIFY.
Okay.
Let's check bot.
Yeah. I don't think gonna be bot. Okay.
Radify.
Let me copy this.
I'm switching to another
window.
I want to show the logs.
Okay.
The logs are important. I will we can
switch to this window later.
So let's switch back.
So now we have a gatekeeper. We have
a ratified, provide date to gatekeeper.
We now we needed to set up the
policies.
Okay.
This is the template file,
according to the gatekeeper.
And,
we need another one. I will explain it
soon.
Okay. You'll see we just applied the template
and the constraints.
Why we need to do that?
So today, I demoed the
the behind off the scene. Actually, if you
want to use the managed experience, you don't
have to do that.
So I have these two file on my
on my file system.
So let's expand the template file first.
Maybe
not,
maybe we can use this way.
Okay.
So is this template,
constraint template, required by Gatekeeper?
Please remember this name, Radifier Revocation.
And you see, this is actually
a policy written in
regular language.
So Gatekeeper
is
using the OPA,
Open Policy Agent.
Actually, the policy is code as policy. So
in our case, it is using Rego.
So in this case, you will see
for example, I skipped some other details. You
can
check later. So
I jump to the bottom. You can see
if it is not success,
it will print out this block.
Right? And it will verify
whether remote data, for example, in our case,
RADify provided
has some errors.
Okay?
So please remember these keyboards.
This is actually a policy
we,
write in a very a very simple policy
for the for the,
for our, demo.
We will see the constraint.
You see, this is also according to Gatekeeper.
You'll see this
is a constraint for the ratified case, and
you see the enforcement action. This is quite
important.
This means that if any failures,
we will deny the deployment
of the contended images.
So in our case, if second nature verification
failed,
we will deny the deployment. So that means
that image cannot be deployed.
Okay. That that is the purpose. Right?
Because untrusted images
or unsigned images, they cannot be deployed.
Okay. There are other
effects.
For example, if I remember clearly,
there are
warning.
So that means
the image can be deployed, but there will
be some warning logs generated that you needed
to take a look. So this is actually
helpful
Before you are ready for production,
you want to make sure everything works right.
You want to check whether, images are properly
signed to avoid any outage,
during production,
so that you can first
set the enforcement to warning,
so that you can audit the logs to
see whether your images are properly signed,
whether they are any images that should not
be there. So after that, if you are
confident, then you can change the enforcement to
deny,
so that later on, any other images not
assigned by
the person or by the organization you trust
or any outstanding images will be denied.
Okay.
So we have a gatekeeper. We have a
ratify. We have our policy now.
Then let's
try it.
Okay. Yeah.
Okay. I put some
text here so that we know new dogs
are coming from here.
And
so let's firstly try the
signed images.
Demo
signed.
I want to use images
from
image environment.
Okay.
Okay. I think I needed to get it.
Yeah, it could be that I tested this,
I forgot to
delete the port.
Nothing that kubectl delete pod dash dash old
can't fix.
Far too quick to reach for the dash
dash all.
Okay.
Yeah.
The delete takes time, I agree. Yeah.
Even longer than the installation.
Let's check. Oh, it's because you're using a
sleep statement, which wouldn't respect Okay. The the
signals.
So it's waiting for the sec kill to
happen after thirty seconds. That's all.
Ah,
I think you are right. Yeah. Now that's
sleep demo, so many times I know the
the gotchas. Okay.
This is created. It's signed images, so let's
check a log.
Okay. This is the new log.
Yeah. After this text.
So
isSuccess
true? Right?
This is the images, if you remember this
digest.
And it's verified by the notation
verifier.
This is the artifact tab. As I explained,
that RADify support verify
other artifact tab. So in our case today,
it is the signature.
This is the
certificate
information.
Okay? So that's the reason the product can
be deployed.
Let's try again
to deploy an unsigned images. I have one
in
the DocHub.
It is not signed.
So
let's check this.
We use for us to discover whether they
are signature.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there's no signature, just these
images.
So that's
wrong
unsigned.
Okay.
You see,
yeah, denied, because we set the deny, right?
If you remember this name, it is the
constraint name. You can also customize it with
your name.
And this is actually the message.
Follow the format that's defined in the policy.
Right? So that means the admission controller gatekeeper
check the data received from RADIFY.
The verification is failed,
and then it produces this message, and it
then denied the request according to the policy.
Then let's switch to RADIFY to see whether
it is really
yeah.
This one is for the NET monitor.
This one is I think it's for us.
Yes.
For the on-site.
This is a force. This is on-site.
This is the char
field.
And the RADIFY produce these messages
to and send it to gatekeeper.
And the gatekeeper,
according to the template and entity constraint, makes
the decision.
Okay. Perfect. Yeah.
So just now we demoed
how to prevent
untrusted images to be deployed on your Kubernetes
cluster. And I explained the behind the scene
the logic for
for it. And also,
user has the flexibility
to customize their policy using regular languages, and
in the future, we will support the CL
cell
languages,
and the user can customize the error messages
and also customize the effect,
whether they want to deny or just
read some warning logs.
Okay. So in production
yeah, in production, for example, on
your premise Kubernetes,
you can install Gatekeeper, Ratify by yourself if
you want to do this customization.
Or you can use Wonder Solutions
error policy plus ratify,
WorkKeep or no, something like that. Yeah. It's
purely
dependent on your own environment.
But the idea is the same. The logic
is the same. Yeah.
Okay. I think that's the last one.
Yeah.
It's a long process.
Wow. So I
can't believe you just did a demo for
over an hour and I don't think anything
actually went wrong. Like that was fantastic.
Well done.
Thank you.
Recap that just to make sure we covered
everything. Then I've got a couple of questions
as well.
What we started off with was
building a container image. You use Buildx and
then the OCI layout. We could take a
look into that manifest and understand exactly what's
going on there.
We learned how to use ORS, particularly useful
there I think was the ORS discover command,
which is fantastic for seeing what information we
have on OCI artifacts within an OCI registry.
Then took a look at the notation command.
So there was a lot going on with
the notary stuff there. Right? There's a generate
test command to generate test keys. But really
in production, what we want people to do
there is use HashiCorp Vault or any of
the KMS providers from Azure, AWS, and dual
cloud, etcetera.
Those allow you to sign artifacts and then
push those signatures with push the new image
with the signatures and the manifest to the
registry.
And even if that would have been a
fantastic demo, but then we moved further into
the realm of Kubernetes, taking a look at
how we can use a combination
of gatekeeper archive,
you said,
web ratify inside of the cluster.
So what I got there is that ratify
is connecting to these policy engines within the
cluster. The two main ones are OPA and
gatekeeper and cavernal
where it allows you to then provide
validation hooks that just
verify that whatever you want in the cluster
is saying, there's a few questions there that
we can go into, but
I don't think any stone was left unturned
there. Pretty much showed us an entire pipeline
from start to finish, which is fantastic.
I think the question I had
that was front and center for me was,
is the integration with Kiverrno and Gatekeeper
there because people already have these things in
the cluster hopefully,
Like why isn't ratify its own validation admission
controller? Could it be run-in that fashion or
is it dependent on Kivernal and Gatekeeper to
some degree?
Yeah,
for X-ray for Kiboto, it does not need
to ratify. Kiboto is self is at the
vision control and itself already
integrated with
supporting the Notre projects in nature. Right. So
for Kibono case, you do not need to
install ratify.
You can, write Kibana YAML file similar as
the trust policy I I show. That is
the JSON format, but in Kibana,
it is a YAML file that cook this
native configuration
style. So you just configure that to validate
another project signature,
and then you put your root state certificate
there, and then you set up some trust
policy. So similar as a RADIFY, but for
Kibana case, you don't need to
use Ratify as data
provider.
But for Gatekeeper,
you needed to use that because Gatekeeper
is more flexible framework.
Can
I mean, user, you can plug in any
data, external data? So in our case, it
is RADIFY.
But I want to say that for RADIFY,
so currently,
the main scenario is working with Gatekeeper
at
the admission control level.
But the ratify in the community,
we also have the vision
to verify
support with policy
in the CICD pipeline.
So for notation,
you can only validate the signature because that
is the notation job. But the ratify, as
I mentioned, it can validate other artifacts
and also ratify support of this rego policy.
To ratify,
we also plan to
have ratify integrated with any CICD system or
even in a simple script.
Just use ratify
with the rego policy or sale policy
to validate the signature,
spawn,
vulnerability,
any artifacts.
And Artify is also capable
to integrate with ContenderD.
So if you check the RADIFY community, we
have a demo, we may have a POC
with ratify
integrated with candida D so that we
can actually validate the image on the node
level so just now what I show is
from the cluster level
for the elevation control,
right? But
to integrate with the Candidate, it can validate
the image from the node level. So RADIFY
is capable to do
many things. It is just at the current
phase.
It is just donated to the since they've
at the sandbox project last year,
we are
mainly focusing on gatekeeper,
this
story, but later on, we will move on
to implement other scenarios.
That could be some new opportunities I can
join this
podcast to to showcase
something in the future. Yeah. I mean, two
fantastic things there. First, the common expression language,
the cell support.
I've spoken to many people and I have
tried myself to write Reagle.
I find it very difficult. So being able
to support cell, I think is a great
and present developer experience for people, I believe.
And also the container D integration is fantastic
because
we've ratify web gatekeeper.
It can get past the validation checks and
then the API server, but what container D
actually pulls to the cluster is a completely
different attack surface. So that integration is also
phenomenal there. That's fantastic stuff. The only other
question that I had front and center, but
the other question I had at the back
of my mind was when we done the
notation commands, you did turn on
notary experimental
features.
What is the plan there then to get
that away from experimental and generally available for
everyone to start considering today? Yeah.
So we actually have this OCR layout support
years ago.
So why it is experimental
is because at that time, OCR image layout
is not well
is not widely
adopted in the in the build system. So
normally,
people will just be able to push to
the registry.
So
for the OCI image layout, it is not
wildly
adopted yet,
and also
people needed to do some changes on their
builder system to produce the OCA image layout.
And also from publishing image point of view,
they also needed to maybe modify their current
publishing process
to transfer these files to some
environment or storages.
So that is the main purpose. Main reason,
it is in the
experimental feature
status.
But
with recently, you noticed that even
Docker desktop support the content ID, right,
the runtime.
So that is open another door for the
OCI image nodes. And we see there will
be many folks, many
scenarios or
real world examples
will come. Because with Candidate,
so before that, if you use Docker to
build, and you can use Docker save, right,
save something or even save a Docker table.
But that Docker table is Docker format.
It is not standardized.
But with Candida D engine,
you use Docker, say, you actually can save
OCR image out.
So people, they don't know the the the
Tableau format,
so normally they just use it. But
the Docker table format, actually,
when you load it,
the digest, you needed to check the digest
dataset.
But with OCI image layout, as I just
showcased,
with the Identity support, Docker save OCI image
layout format. It is the standard according to
the OCI
standard. It can be distributed
anywhere
with
the unified identity digest not changed.
That is the
I see that is the
movement that in the future, the OSA image
layout could be
popular used.
So when that comes, we will
make this feature stable for you. That that
is the
background about this.
Awesome.
Well,
that was fantastic. Thank you so much for
taking time out of your day to sit
here show us how to make our container
images secure from local dev all the way
into production.
So you will be in London. So if
anyone is watching us before KubeCon London, make
sure to go and see these talks. And
I'm assuming you'll maybe be on the
maintainer booths for Notary and for Ratify. Right?
Yeah. But in
yeah. I will be on the project booths,
not a project, definitely. And for ORs, I'm
a contributor. I can also answer questions.
I will also host the Docker project, the
maintenance track, the a separate session.
I will also have a lightning talk, introduce
some new features.
Keeping yourself busy. Yeah.
Yeah.
So
yeah. Welcome. So that's hopefully, we can meet
in
person at the moment. Yeah.
Alright.
Well, thank you so much for all your
contributions. You know, security and container stuff is
not always glamorous, but it is so paramount,
the future of what we're doing with Kubernetes
and cloud native. So to you and all
the other maintainers of all these projects, thank
you so much for your time and effort.
Thank you. Thank you, David. You you did
a very good summary just now. Basically, captured
everything.
I know this is
I I said that before,
it will be around twenty minutes. Right? But
during
the hands on process, I explained it actually
takes
one hour or fourteen minutes.
But you captured everything
for the for the key key parts. That
is very good. And also, I noticed at
the beginning, you played that music.
It's a very it's actually a customized music.
Yeah. Yeah. They are integrity
sign published.
Think that is really good. Maybe you can
share that
to me. Will share with the community. That
is fantastic.
Yeah. Yes, I will share that with you.
Feel free to drop that into your Slack
channels or whatever you want with people. But
again,
this is the least I can do to
tell the amazing contributors and maintainers out there
making open source more secure.
Thank you so much again.
Yeah. Thank you.
Alright. Well, have a great day, a great
weekend. I'll hopefully see you in London and
to everyone who watched. We hope you found
this useful
and until next time. Bye. Yep. Same to
you.
Bye.
Bringing you these deep dives into the cloud
native world. Don't forget to like, subscribe, and
hit that notification
bell so you never miss a session. Keep
building,
keep learning,
and keep it secure.
We'll see you next time.
Peace out.